scully great to have you in and and of
course lots to talk about rather closer
to your brief but let's start with that
we are once again seeing in ukraine
president biden has once again issued
concerns about russian potential use of
biological or chemical weapons if those
were to be used that would undoubtedly
be a war crime wouldn't it yeah
undoubtedly and uh i think you know uh
president biden and prime minister have
been really resolute in making sure that
uh we can take every action with the
international community to um address
those those crimes of vladimir putin
we've got to remember as well with all
of this is that this is vladimir putin's
war against russia and kremlin's war
against russia against ukraine it's not
the russian people so we've got to make
sure that uh we can appeal to the
russian people uh to to bring an end to
this those in ukraine will of course be
concerned as to whether or not this is
president biden speculating on the basis
of you know the russians in various
parts of the country or perhaps whether
as has happened on a number of occasions
in the past the americans are revealing
intelligence do you know which of those
it might be i don't know it's the honest
answer but you know i wouldn't like to
speculate cool
just in terms of of the sanctions there
have been a couple of super yachts that
have been moved around recently italy um
has been urged to to seize the super
yacht allegedly linked to vladimir putin
uh that shahid has added i mean
is that the type of action that we would
wish to see and there's the boat i mean
it's pretty big you can't miss it i mean
would you support the italians in taking
that type of well i think what i can
talk about is what we've done we've
we've sanctioned more than a thousand
individuals and entities we've been very
much on the front foot in uh passing the
economic crime bill which i did last uh
last week which uh included uh
registering the ownership of um or the
the the um the beneficial ownership of
um properties within the uk so that we
can use that as a tool to better
sanction target sanctions against the
individuals that are supportive of putin
just just on that point though i mean
how close are we really to knowing who
owns these large empty buildings that we
see scattered around knightsbridge and
so on well i think with that's exactly
what that register is there to do uh
what it will do is uh when people have
bought something through a shell company
they will have to register who actually
owns it who's the beneficial owner of it
now there's 95 000 odd properties that
are involved in that and most of those
clearly are not owned by oligarchs it's
important to remember that many many
people use those for legitimate reasons
but uh it will give us a useful tool for
the um intelligence agencies and
enforcement agencies to be able to
target the right people yeah one day
i'll have a legitimate reason to own a
50 million pound mansion and let's
though let's let's move on to your
briefing and in terms of piano fairies
the accusation has been from
particularly from those who have been
sacked who haven't signed non-disclosure
agreements is that you heard about it
the night before they were told over a
zoom call and did nothing about it i
just want to give you the opportunity to
to counter that allegation no oh it's
it's incorrect i mean i i knew nothing
about it but the secretary of state was
informed the night before that the
company was going was going to be
announcing redundancies the following
day um not as in the debate we heard
yesterday that there were going to be uh
balaclava wearing um uh security guards
or anything like that and the uh piano
fairies
have made redundancies over the last
couple of years each year over the last
couple of years as well because they are
in a not good financial state and so he
expected it to be going along the same
way as those redundancies announced
previously rather than the situation
that we've seen the absolute egregious
situation that we've seen so it's just
to be absolutely clear despite the
transport secretary told that 800 people
were were potentially about to lose
their jobs he didn't feel it was
necessary for either him or any of his
junior ministerial colleagues to pick up
the phone and speak to piano fairies
well what normally happens with
redundancies if we get if you're in a
situation where you say there is going
to be announcement that normally that's
an announcement of
the consultation the notification that
is required um under the law and bear it
in mind that the notification which is
why i and my boss quasi quartet have
written to the chief exec of piano
factories to get further detail because
it's important that we get the exact
detail not just
the various um amounts of media stories
that we're getting we need to collate it
in one place because there are criminal
sanctions uh
involved in this so including an
unlimited fine for which which is all
which is all post hoc unfortunately the
complaint that is being made by the
staff is that in those few hours that
window of opportunity before that zoom
call came and before those sackings were
issued there was an opportunity for the
government to speak to p and o ferries
now i understand that after the fact
when you've heard all of these details
you're utterly aghast but surely before
the announcement was made should have
been the opportunity for this government
to put in a check call doesn't even have
to be a minister a civil servant could
have done it i mean to be fair just the
the you know the hours
that we had before was
not even enough time to step up our uh
department working pensions uh team let
alone actually try to reverse the
decision but nonetheless we have said to
piano fairies first thing get round the
table reverse the decision speak to the
union speak to the workers but it is
perfectly possible that what piano
ferries have done is entirely legal
they're not flagged in the united
kingdom they sail in international
waters the allegation is that they have
hired in indian agency staff on less
than two pounds an hour and it could
potentially be perfectly legal there is
nothing as of seven o'clock this morning
to stop another company from doing
exactly this if they're operating in
similar circumstances to penalties well
this is the complication it's about
jurisdiction a lot of this is about
jurisdiction as you say it was the
vessel isn't flagged within the uk
uh i understand that contracts may not
have been signed within the uk um either
and that this is all the things that
we're trying to determine nonetheless
the point still stands if it is a
business
on land in the uk within your uk
jurisdiction there are plenty of laws in
place which which carry criminal
sanctions are we going to change the law
though to prevent firing and rehiring
well this wasn't really a case of fire
and rehab because it said it was said it
said in the memo circulated by the dft
that their ambition was too far and reha
at more favorable conditions
that was in the civil servants note but
the but the ambition was to rehear other
people uh so there was you know you've
got 800 people sitting now in the uk
without a job that had no opportunity of
going back to the job and that's why
that consultation uh was is so important
but this is this was a case of mass
sackings that were done in the most
callous way okay so what are we going to
do about it so as i said we're
establishing the fact now we we're
expecting it we're expecting an answer
if it proves that they haven't acted
illegally if they haven't acted
illegally under english law maritime law
what are we going to do well if if they
have then what we absolutely reserve
the right to approach prosecuting
authorities to to tackle this if we if
we haven't uh then obviously we want to
make sure that we can support the um the
800 people who have lost their jobs to
make sure that they can uh get back into
into into good work
but we'll have to work with um
international partners because this is
as you say a complex uh web of
international maritime law um when you
have vessels flagged with other
other countries i i do want to take you
away from your brief again we'll return
to just at the end um nazanin's gary
radcliffe spoke spoke very movingly
yesterday about her years in
incarceration and indeed her complaint
that successive foreign secretaries
could have sorted this out if as we were
told by this trust the other day that
this was a debt that this was an
obligation that we had to the iranians
of 400 million pounds there of their
abouts
if that was a debt that we owed on the
last day of her incarceration it was a
debt that we owed on the first day of
incarceration so i will ask again the
question that she asked why didn't we
pay it before her well first of all it
was a such a pleasure to see nasa
and looking in such good shape as well
i'd seen her after all she's been
through i'd seen richard throughout both
of his hunger strikes and uh you know he
he um he really suffered as did she as
did her family so it's lovely to see her
back but clearly what we had to do uh
the government had to do is to make sure
that um yes it was a debt that that uh
that was there to be paid it was worked
in in parallel but it was a complex
situation to make sure that that debt
worked alongside sanctions uh from a
number of countries around the world
with with iran that was you know it's
not something that was relatively easy
to to sort out but huge but you rewind
you're going to december 2017 when one
boris johnson was foreign secretary and
was trying to secure nazim's release you
know the line from downing street at
that point was there was absolutely no
link between the debt and nasanan's
incarceration in fact it was only in may
2019 the sunday times went to court to
get documents published that showed that
this debt was at the heart of it so
again we also learned that here that two
defense secretaries sir michael fallon
and gavin williamson remember him had
also said no to a foreign office request
for the money to be paid out of the
defense budget there were opportunities
over the six years for this money to be
paid and the government chose not to do
so so doesn't necessarily have a point i
think that as i say the debts were the
debt and her release were ran in
parallel but uh but there was just a
coincidence that but there's a place in
the same day well there's a complex set
of um um approaches with the
international community when you've got
the us with sanctions against iran when
you've got us with sanctions against
iran it's very very difficult to um to
have have those any closer together
for fear of what what other what
otherwise might happen in a similar
situation given um kidnaps giving
ransoms and stuff in other parts of the
world
again though naznen's line is if this
money had anything to do with my release
six years into my incarceration
why could it not have been done early
you can understand her i can understand
her frustration frankie what she's gone
through is horrendous so i can totally
understand her uh her frustration and i
as i say having met richard um
a few times i've seen the the the pain
and anguish of the family over that
period as well so all i can do now now
she is back i'm really pleased she's
back and i'm glad that liz trust acted
the way she did and got her out
resolutely that she can put this behind
her somehow and rebuild that uh time
with her family we have 30 seconds left
in the interview so i suspect you're not
going to give me all the details of the
spring statement tomorrow so why don't
you at least tell me what it is going to
be designed to achieve well look we are
we've got a lot of headwinds uh that
everybody is facing businesses and um
and individuals as well and it's so
important that uh the chancellor will be
looking at the public finances in the
round to make sure he can continue to
flex and support people in difficult
times minister great to have you on
thanks for being with us